ce
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on
discute et on échange sur des sujets qui
font l'actualité des artistes en
résidence dans un établissement de santé
avec culture à l'hôpital
des patients ont pu découvrir la danse
le chant ou encore la musique le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines est allé
hors les murs à l'hôpital pédiatrique de
bullion avec la compagnie fait de galles
en une résidence dont le fruit est à
découvrir dans un documentaire à
l'occasion d'une soirée à la scène
nationale on parle de ce projet avec nos
invités ma qualif magali cabrol bonsoir
vous êtes la directrice de l'action
culturelle du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la scène
nationale béatrice massin bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes chorégraphe et
directrice artistique de fêtes galantes
la compagnie en résidence à l'hôpital de
bullion et martin gaboriau bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
pédagogique de l'hôpital pédiatrique de
rééducation 1,2 million alors depuis son
lancement au niveau français mais en
2004 culture à l'hôpital c'est plus de
260 actions artistiques c'est un
programme piloté par l' agence régionale
de santé la direction régionale des
affaires culturelles avec l'appui de
l'association ar santé la manufacture et
le soutien du département des abymes et
de la mutuelle dans notre call les
ménages prévoyance a fait beaucoup de
monde
magali cabrol pourquoi est ce que le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
s'est lancé dans ce projet bah écoutez
je dois dire que ça fait vraiment de
nombreuses années qu'on avait vraiment
cette envie là de d'investir le milieu
hospitalier de deux de s'adresser à ce
public on appelle empêché parce qu'il a
des difficultés à venir jusque jusque
dans nos lieux
et puis et puis ça s'est fait à la lie
des c'était 2-2 avoir bien de faire une
belle rencontre et la belle rencontre
elle a eu lieu il ya deux ans avec avec
daniel roth qui est le cadre
socio-éducatif de le cadre éducatif de
l'achever m
de bullion et nous on l'a sollicité on
me proposait d'abord un spectacle dans
les murs de l'hôpital il a fait preuve
d'un grand enthousiasme
ça s'est extrêmement bien passée et ça a
été la première pierre d'un partenariat
au long cours qui désormais a fait ces
deux c'est son deuxième anniversaire
voilà ça fait deux ans qu'on travaille
avec avec grand plaisir dans cet
établissement hospitalier
alors demain soir jeudi 1er juillet il
ya une soirée spéciale au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec notamment
la diffusion du documentaire de thomas
bailly à propos de cette résidence et
avant qu'on parle un peu plus du travail
effectué et je vous propose qu'on
regarde un extrait
[Musique]
quand on fait ça est-ce que vous pouvez
vous faire tourner votre fauteuil une
fois hélas donc tu choisisses main
droite main gauche comme s'est plu à
fait les enlèvent en fait du corps
médical ça nous enlève de nous aussi
nous nous sommes éducatrice et ils ont
une autre approche et qu'il ya des
nouvelles voix des nouveaux sombre des
nouvelles sensations une pièce qui
découvre aussi qu'ils sont pas tellement
habitué voilà se trouve que c'est très
riche et il se passe vraiment des
connexions espace des jolies choses
est ce qu'un danseur pour faire un peu
la même chose à votre cher comme ceux
qui les lie dans des bois tu ferais quoi
qu'en mouvement pour montrer qu'on est
libre
[Musique]
on était épaté hier damien a commencé à
danser au son de la voix de cet enfant
qui est d'être appelé gic et qui a juste
des claquements de langue et des baisers
sommes son doigt et quand il a commencé
à comprendre que damien danser sur sa
musique à lui ça a été un moment mais
une magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça qui est chouette et c'est
peut-être ça aussi juste notre victoire
c'est d'avoir été jusqu'au bout d'une
chose d'un mouvement
c'est peut-être un moment qui est
éphémère mais on sait que ça chemine
c'est des rencontres qui sont pas
anodines on n'est pas ici pour
et béatrice massin dans cet extrait on
vous entend parler d'une relation qui se
noue entre damian l'un des danseurs est
l'un des enfants c'est les moments forts
de cette résidence aussi ce lien qui se
loupe ce qui se nouent absolument
absolument c'est ça qui a été je pense
l'élément essentiel c'est d'arriver au
travers de nos métiers d'artistes aussi
bien chanteur que pianiste que danseur
d'arriver à passer des liens et de l'ain
team et une complicité corporelle
finalement complètement au niveau
d'essence avec tous les enfants quel que
soit leur état
je pense qu'on est arrivé à construire
aussi un travail commun avec tous les
groupes et c'était important que les
enfants aient la sensation des groupes
mais on a été vraiment al intime de
chacun et un os intime à nous et nous
aussi merci le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et merci
bullion parce que nous aussi on est
complètement transformé par cette
expérience
martin gaboriau c'est un sentiment cette
transformation que vous avez vu du côté
des patients des élèves
alors c'est vrai que pendant toute cette
scène bonne partie d'année se travaille
avec la compagnie béatrice matin a
vraiment donné une évolution assez
impressionnante de l'appropriation de ce
projet par les élèves
parce qu'effectivement comme la guille
magali la particularité d au niveau du
mythe l enseignement c'est que nous
travaillons des élèves qui sont malades
donc leur leur priorité c'est de prendre
soin de leur santé
et effectivement lorsqu'on peut leur
faire partager des moments de rencontres
avec des artistes où ils vont pouvoir
s'exprimer d'une toute autre façon que
ce qu'ils peuvent avoir l'habitude de
faire dans les temps de classe c'est
vraiment un grand bénéfice pour pour les
élèves et c'est vrai que pour le coup
c'est une mise en oeuvre concrète du
parcours d'éducation artistique et
culturelle que doivent parcourir donc
les les élèves
donc ce travail a été vraiment moins
très très riche et je dois dire que les
magali magail
béatrice et les artistes ont vraiment su
se mettre au service des élèves et donc
prendre en compte les biens lors leur
particularité
le fait que ce sont d'abord et avant
tout des enfants malades et donc pour
pouvoir leur donner un espace de
création qui est quand même très très
riches oui magali cabrol c'était aussi
la mission c'est que ce sont des enfants
malades
j'ai du mal à vous entendre la connexion
à désolé il n'y a pas de souci je disais
est ce que c'est aussi ça la mission du
théâtre de saint quentin ont parlé d'un
public empêcher mais là c'est un public
empêcher jeunes est malade
oui oui oui c'est exactement ça mais en
même temps on s'adresse à eux alors
évidemment il faut il faut être dans une
adaptation permanente dans une grande
écoute dans une bienveillance absolue
mais mais je crois que je crois que
travail il est de la même nature il est
de la même exigence qu'avec qu'avec
d'autres
d'autres types de populations de public
je vois là je crois que c'est ça
finalement la valeur ajoutée aussi de
ces projets là c'est vraiment de d'être
dans quelque chose de
tu es de nouvelles mesures d'allègement
de nous les considérer comme des
citoyens à part entière c'est vraiment
la vocation de ce projet là c'est
vraiment faire en sorte que ces jeunes
gens puissent vraiment être des ddd
tenir à la cité quoi complètement et
l'accès à l'art et à la culture basque
s'est fait partie des droits des
citoyens
voilà si je pouvais dire qu'ils ne sont
pas empêchés
ils sont en effet malade comme disait si
tu y as martin gaboriau et c'est avec
leur maladie qu'il faut arriver à
rentrer dans leur humanité
mais ils n'ont rien empêché ils sont
comme nous ils sont absolument comme
nous et il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
aller avec eux sur un geste artistique
beatriz maintenant je voulais rester
avec vous ce que les fêtes galantes
c'est une compagnie de danse baroque qui
met du xviie et xviiie siècles au 21ème
siècle est ce que il y a eu au départ
une barrière avec certains de ses
patients de ses élèves que c'est un art
qui ne connaissent pas nécessairement
non il n'y a pas une barrière parce que
mon travail n'est pas du tout sûr l'idée
de construire des barrières mais bien au
contraire de faire les choses des plus
contemporaines possible à partir d'une
culture et d'une connaissance et que
surtout cette culture convoqué quelque
chose qui a été essentielle d'envoi de
ce projet qui était le champ et que à
cette époque là le chanson la danse ou
la danse sans le champ n'ont pas de sens
et on a permis du cou à des enfants de
chanter de chanter et danser ensemble
c'est un geste totalement baroque mais
c'est un geste de plaisir du bape unième
siècle qu'il ne faut pas qu'on oublie
martin gaboriau justement comment vous
l'avez intégré dans l'aspect pédagogique
dans l'évolution de ces de ses enfants
eh bien écoutez comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure le parcours d'éducation
artistique et culturelle fait partie
intégrante des programmes de l'éducation
nationale
quel que soit l'âge l'âge des élèves et
donc c'est bien à partir du travail qui
était fait avec les artistes les
enseignants n'ont pu se saisir de ces
moments pour ensuite les retravailler
les re tricoté en classe et faire en
sorte que ce projet
puissent avoir une vie pendant tout le
temps des à tenir et au delà parce que
ce qu'il faut préciser c'est que au
départ le temps prévu pour le la partie
scolaire et aient été réduits et
finalement les aléas calendaire ont fait
que les enseignantes ont ramené du temps
pour travailler avec béatrice et et les
artistes et vraiment on a vu cette
évolution et comment à la fois les ens
les enseignants et leurs élèves étaient
complètement appliquée dans projet ait
été au coeur du projet sert que les
enseignantes étaient là pour danser
chanter au même titre que leurs élèves
et par rapport au chant je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que dit béatrice
on a vu certains élèves se révéler dans
le champ avec un plaisir vraiment très
très important de pouvoir participer
avec par une chanteuse professionnelle
des artistes professionnels et c'est
vrai que cette rencontre a été vraiment
magnifique et il ya des gens que j'ai
dit oui c'est par rapport à l'exigence
ont perlé béatrice c'est vrai que nous
avons des enfants malades
mais pour autant l'exigence elle est
tout à fait nécessaire et c'est
l'exigence un aspect des élèves aussi et
donc le fait de proposer de l'art
baroque qui a priori comme vous le
disiez ne n'est pas forcément un champ
vers lequel les enfants les adolescents
se tourne c'est vraiment justement être
dans l'exigence et le respect de ses
élèves
je pense que ça serait eu vraiment ne
pas les respecter leur proposer des
choses qu'ils ont l'habitude de
d'entendre tout le temps donc ça c'est
aussi quelque chose de très important
cette exigence je peux préciser je vois
quelque chose
c'est vrai qu'on parle on évoque
beaucoup les jeunes patients et à juste
titre je tenais quand même à rappeler
que le dispositif culture à l'hôpital a
pour vocation à s'adresser à l'ensemble
de la communauté sanitaire à l'ensemble
des personnels de la shnpm là en
l'occurrence alors on va peut-être y
venir mais c'est vrai que les conditions
sanitaires en sacrément
perturber leur mise en oeuvre du projet
même si au final il a lieu dans son
intégralité
mais voilà on aurait souhaité on a
imaginé une présence une participation
des personnels
c'est vrai que ça c'est pas tout à fait
bien gagner des choses mais c'est vrai
que ça n'a pas pu se développer de la
manière pour la veille
on l'avait imaginé oui cette résidence
vraiment essence et voilà rayonner sur
l'ensemble de l'établissement et et
décloisonnée aussi les services c'est
très important aussi de faire en sorte
que les différents services puissent
prendre part à un projet commun un
projet collectif
oui justement comment vous avez adapté
on le voit à l'image d'être masqué on se
doute bien que c'est en pleine crise
sanitaire
béatrice massa comment est ce que vous
avez aussi adapter cette période où on
parle de distanciation social tout le
temps de mettre 2 mètres entre les
personnes comment est-ce qu'un
chorégraphe adapte son travail avec
cette question là alors on a fait
beaucoup de tests
on a beaucoup porté nos masques on s'est
engagé à changer de vêtements entre
chaque séance avec chaque groupe pour
permettre quand même d'avoir des
contacts physiques avec les enfants et
d'avoir des contacts physiques aussi
avec tout le personnel médical et tout
le personnel de l'éducation nationale
qui ont été avec nous présent dans les
séances de travail c'est à dire que
comme nous nous étions très exigeants
par rapport aux règles qui nous avait
été donnée ça a été possible de
prolonger ce travail et de le mener
jusqu'à terme en étant masqué à chaque
fois les enfants ne nous ont jamais vue
démasqué au démarrage en était très
gênée donc même les les artistes et
intervenants en disant faire un concert
pour des chanteurs avec d'un masque
c'était un effort même physique au-delà
de leurs habitudes et finalement ben je
crois que tu oublié qu'on avait des
marques telles des choses fortes et
maniable annonce allait naturellement le
projet s'est transformé il n'est pas
tout à fait comme il devait être
mais qu'importe c'est pas ça qui compte
ce qui passe ce qui compte c'est
vraiment ce qui a été vécu partagé avec
nous tous est partagée aussi bien avec
les adultes qui entourait les enfants
que les enfants une martin gaboriau on a
parlé de vos élèves qui ont évolué vous
avez parlé de l'implication des du corps
enseignant de tous ces adultes qui
accompagnent les enfants est-ce que vous
avez vu aussi les adultes changé
peut-être même vous même alors moi ce
que j'ai vu bon je parlerai
essentiellement des enseignants puisque
je travaille au sein de l'unité
d'enseignement ce que ce que j'ai vu
c'est une application de plus en plus
forte est vraiment un plaisir important
pour les enseignantes de pouvoir
partager au 6 septembre créatif avec
leur ep et avec les artistes
c'est à dire que pendant les ateliers on
n'avait pas un enseignant et que ses
élèves et des artistes on avait vraiment
des individus qui créent ensemble qu'ils
partageaient un stand est qui qui était
dans une forme de comment dire une forme
de wi de partage pour travailler
ensemble créent ensemble un objet je
vais dire un objet culturel et ça c'est
c'était vraiment spectaculaire en les
parties de la de la rencontre départ on
ne sait pas trop où on va mais c'est
normal on a cherché ensemble je prends
beaucoup cherchent sur le centre avec
béatrice et et les artistes qui ont
guidé pour finalement ben produire
ensemble quelque chose un objet
artistique vraiment de très grande
qualité
alors est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que
l'hôpital de bullion garde cette qu'on
veut dire ateliers pour plus tard
refaire des productions alors
effectivement il ya il ya d'autres
projets artistiques et culturels à à
l'hôpital depuis tenons donc
effectivement pour l'année prochaine il
y aura aussi un autre partenariat avec
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dans le dans lequel lieder commune sera
bien de faire participer les patients
c'est à dire à la fois les enfants
patients les enfants élèves pour créer
une dynamique
bunce en ce sens sans cloisonnement
c'est ce que disait magali l'idée de
faire participer tout le monde un objet
culturel et c'est vrai que mon espère
vraiment grandement que les conditions
sanitaires dont on savait de façon à ce
qu'on puisse faire travailler ensemble
les différents teams c'est parce que
c'est évident que cette année on n'a pas
plus au temps partagé que nous aurions
souhaité patrice mas à ce que vous vous
imagineriez dans les années prochaines
créer une pièce avec cette expérience là
je ne sais pas je pense que tout à toute
aventure pédagogique de toute façon
oriente aussi la création c'est à dire
que je ne suis pas différente quand je
suis pédagogue et quand je suis au
travail avec des danseurs professionnels
je pense que l'humanité de cette
aventure aux rapports bligg à thouars
mandé résonance sur des créations
prochaine et elle en a même sur le
travail là pour le moment avec les
danseurs avec lesquels je travaille je
pense que c'est plus à prendre
finalement apprendre à découvrir le nez
et la sincérité au fond de soi même
plutôt que de se dire qu'on va faire une
pièce pour des enfants malades et exhibé
des promenades sur un plateau cette
démarche là me semblerait presque un peu
vicieuse quelque part un peu perverse
alors que je pense que l'âme on érige
tous et d'une honnêteté une sincérité
dans toutes les rencontres
et ça je pense que c'est un des plus
beaux apprentissage finalement de de
cette empathie qu'on a vécu avec eux et
magali cas vraiment madame kerboriou
nous a donné quelques indices déjà mes
skis à d'autres résidences de ce type
qui sont prévus dans le cadre de culture
et santé en et de france avec le théâtre
de saint quentin ce qu'il y aura
d'autres structures mobilisés sur ce
septième balle de set je sais pas en
tout cas en tout cas nous avons
déjà préparé le le projet de l'année
prochaine de 2021 2022
il s'agira à nouveau de poursuivre la
découverte d'un langage chorégraphique
d'un univers chorégraphiques et ce sera
l'année prochaine celui de joanne
leighton
voilà qui est une chorégraphe belgo
australienne cette année en france 1 en
ile de france et qui propose un lacet
quelqu'un donc elle est australienne et
elle est vraiment nourrit pétri de toute
la culture aborigène
il y aura notamment un voilà un travail
de découverte de cette culture là
l'univers pictural tout le travail des
symboles
voilà je crois que ça va être une
résidence à nouveau très très riche
après moi vraiment je tenais à dire que
enfin voila je tenais à remercier
vraiment un très très chaleureusement
béatrice vous savez au coeur d'une au
sein d'une saison qui comporte entre 60
et 70 spectacles c'est à dire qui
accueille entre 60 et 70 équipes
artistiques
je ne plaisante pas quand je dis que
quand j'ai conçu ce projet je savais que
c'était béatrice et personne d'autre
voilà ça demande des qualités tout à
fait tout à fait particulière vraiment
l'a déjà dit mais je le redis
d'adaptation de bienveillance de de bons
positionnements et voilà c'est je suis
ravi d'avoir travaillé avec elle et mais
je suis ravi que ça a apporté beaucoup à
sa fin je sens bien que ça la salle à
bouger aussi vraiment en tant que
quartier franchement des mois absolument
c'est justement pour rome se rendre
compte de cette alchimie qu'il a pu y
avoir en trombe
madame hassen votre compagnie ainsi que
les équipes pédagogiques de madame
gaboriau à l'hôpital de bullion est le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il y à cette diffusion du documentaire
demain soir 1er jeudi 1er juillet à
19h30 après l'une de vos oeuvres madame
bassens de théâtre de saint quentin en
yvelines
je vous propose qu'on s'arrête là le
mieux c'est bien sûr d'aller voir le
documentaire passe
société maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau temps des
changes prenez soin de vous
[Musique]